hello everyone and welcome to the moment
you've all been waiting for it's
the creation grand chester and it's the
blitz section which also marks the
return of gary kasparov to the
chessboard at the age of 58 he will be
joining them
uh instead of ivan charity who was
playing the rapid section and now we
will have two days of blitz
uh and kasparov will again mark his
return with
uh with some uh awesome chess so this is
the first game that
was played he's facing jordan one forest
uh one for us
and some of you have been saying that
i've been pronouncing dutch names
dutch names wrong but it's uh you know
they're not easy to pronounce so if you
ever hear me pronounce the name wrong
my email is public just you know record
it on your smartphone just send it over
and i will
implement it immediately over the course
of the next video so here
someone actually emailed me uh maybe a
year and a half ago that it's actually
pronounced for us
so i'm pronouncing it like that but even
if this is wrong you know feel free to
further educate me and i will learn no
doubt about it
uh so this is the first game of the
first day of the blitz uh because part
of a faces one for us then it's a really
really crazy attacking game
as you can imagine whenever kasparov is
involved there's a crazy attacking game
so without further ado let's check it
out uh jordan with
the white pieces opens with e4 and of
course uh gary the
the attacker that is will go for the
sicilian against uh
e4 so knight to f3 we have d6 and now
d4 so just a normal open sicilian we
have captures captures and the knight to
f6
now knight to c3n kasparov opts for the
knight of sicilian we have bishop to g5
and
now e6 with f4 and queen to c7 so again
this is all very standard stuff
and now the usual way is that white will
just continue developing with queen to
f3 but jordan makes a gary thing he
first goes for bishop captures on f6 so
maybe
kasparov has been out of chess for quite
a long time maybe he's not
um you know maybe maybe he doesn't know
the answer right away
uh but he does he just plays uh g
captures an f6 which okay is the only
move and after queen to f3
he plays b5 and here we have a3 by one
forest uh there are a couple of moves
that are very popular here for example
e5 is very popular castling queen set is
very popular bishop to d3 is very
popular
uh but one forest goes a3 and it is only
now that kasparov has to
uh think about the position here was the
first time that he
started spending some time i just
remembered
let me just check for uh for it a really
really quickly
uh let me just check this uh uh don't
mind me i'm just checking something
i forgot to forgot to check it out uh
before the video so i don't want to
leave you guys hanging
okay we have this and then uh all right
there's that
uh all right
yeah sorry about that uh so like we said
uh here
a3 and here was the first time that
kasparov started thinking for uh about
the position and he went
knight to c6 which is not a new move uh
it has been played before i just had to
check the database real quickly
knight captures on c6 by one forced
queen captures and
now f5 starting the attack against
kasparov's king which is still on e8
here
and kasparov just goes queen to c5 and
it makes sense uh since the queen
doesn't really want to be here we want
to place your bishop on this diagonal
and if you try to capture here it
doesn't really work all that well
because white will not recapture and
allow the trait of queens
white will just castle queenside and
it's going to be a very nasty attack for
black to handle
so here instead after f5 we have queen
to c5 by kasparov and
now comes bishop to e2 uh and uh
now comes a move that is new in the
position so there is one game where
queen back the e5 was played
but here kasparov plays rook to a7 and
it is only now as of move 13 that we
have a completely new game so now the
rook will help out with the defense
along the seventh rank
and also you don't have to worry about
some e5 ideas leaving the rook here
undefended so
rook to a7 and one forest just castles
queen side bringing another attacker
into the game
and here again after some consideration
because paro doesn't uh
continue development then it's very hard
to develop you don't really want to put
your bishop here or here
well not there here or here he just
centralizes the queen with queen to e5
but he already spent a lot of time here
on for
some three minutes and 50 seconds on the
clock uh whereas
kasparov is already down to one minute
and 50 seconds and
yes i know you guys will scold me for
this so let me just
uh update this for uh very briefly
there we go uh now there is now there is
a b on the little robot so
there you have it so here queen to e5 as
this is a blitz game and now
rook h to f1 one for us of course is
expecting this to open up and then he
will already have queen and rook nicely
placed on the file
to be used for attacking purposes so
here rook the c7 caspar
also interested in bringing some
attackers into the game but he still has
some issues developing here these
bishops are still undeveloped the rook
still
stuck on h8 and now evan force just goes
for the nice prophylactic
king to b1 which is mostly what people
do when
when there's a rook on the c file in the
sicilian uh and now
h5 preventing the queen from going to h5
and it's also
a nice pawn you want to advance at stage
four so one forest just pushes h4 and he
plays really quickly kasparov is already
down to one minute
and he's not letting the the old world
champion breed so
bishop to e7 kasparov just continues
developing and
now comes queen to e3 maybe with some
ideas of just bringing the queen over to
b6
so casparo plays queen to c5 he again
offers a queen trade but now
queen back to g3 which was not possible
a move ago as the queen was here on e5
so king the fate kasparov doesn't want
to allow queen to g7 so king the f8 and
now only now have on force opens df file
so f captures
and now uh here the maybe the safe
course of action would be to capture
back with the bishop or maybe even queen
e5 try to go for a temporary pawn
sacrifice uh maybe maybe try
and offer a queen trade but kasparov
boldly captures with the f-pawn now he
has a massive pawn center here
but you know it's only good if it's good
so here we have queen
to g6 now with some ideas of maybe
capturing on f6
so kasparov has to bring a defender into
the game queen to e5 now keeping an eye
on the f6 square
and now comes rook to d3 a very nice
rook clipped by van forest uh leaving
kasparov here with
uh well with a lot of option but what do
you do
because pyro plays bishop to d8 which
makes sense as you want to bring this
rook over to f7 to help out with the
defense
of the f6 square but maybe uh maybe a
bit more
resilient with rook to g8 but this is a
blitz game you know who's to say what's
more resilient so here bishop to d8 by
kasparov
uh and now there's a problem because now
van forest is completely winning here
but only if he finds
one very particular move so feel free to
pause the video here and
win the game for van forst while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not playing
something weird like
rook to f3 or i know some of you guys
were even considering knights to d5
which is fine it's always good to
consider things but for those of you who
found the actual move congratulations as
the movies
rook to g3 now uh there are a lot of
threads here but one is
one is very nasty and the problem here
is that if black just continues
developing and
the this is where the poison in rook to
g3 lies let's say bishop to b7
you want to get a piece into the game
somehow rook g5 just wins the game
that's the problem the f pawn is pinned
and now you don't have a good move if
you play something like f5 well
then uh we can just play bishop captures
on h5 a lot of moves are winning here
you you can even capture with the rook
for example rook captures here
with check and then if punk captures
rook captures wins the queen
and the white of course is completely
winning and if you don't play f5
uh you could move the queen let's say to
d4 but then just bishop captures on f5
and again there's
really no no good move that that defends
this is just a very very ugly position
for black
so instead after rook to g3 kasparov
brings the rook to f7
it's uh you know with heavy with heavy
heart because the rook is
meant here to be used for attacking
purposes but okay now it's a rook that's
uh
supposed to help out with the defense
but now comes rook to g5 this move still
works even though the f file is not uh
not about to open with a with a check to
the black king the problem is
if you capture here then of course you
are getting checkmated in one move so of
course kasparov has to move the queen
he plays queen to d4 but now comes the
move that we've already seen in a
previous line just bishop captures on h5
and he was in this position on move 25
that gary kasparov resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh the problem is queen captures an f7
is the threat of checkmate and
whatever you do there's just no
defending that if you go if you move the
rook to keep an eye on this square
uh then you're getting queen to e8
checkmate the rook covers the entire g
file and if you try something else you
could move the rook somewhere else let's
say the e7
then you run into another very ugly move
rook captures an f6 now the bishop no
longer guards this and after queen
captures it's just a very quick
checkmate queen captures
now the rook casts the block and now
queen captures on f7 or
queen captures and d8 will be checkmate
so uh really really an awesome attacking
game by van forest kasparov tried to
play very actively he
burned a lot of times kasparov usually
does he always comes back for these
blitz games and then he tries to play
really really aggressive attacking chess
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
but
it always burns a lot of time and this
is what was uh i think
uh the the major issue here but of
course that's to be expected when you're
not
uh you know completely fully into chess
you don't have every day all day to
analyze new lines and to prepare for
for new attacks uh and of course one
forest is more than prepared for that so
really awesome attacking game
congratulations to
evan forrest on beating the former world
champion gary kasparov
uh so that's the first game of the blitz
section hope you guys enjoyed it uh
there will be a lot of games so feel
free to use hashtag suggestion for me to
see it
uh and uh try and uh check it out and
analyze a game that you yourself thought
was very interesting
so once again i hope you guys enjoyed it
that's how you attack the sicilian
defense
always you know be very straightforward
push f5 push e5 push everything just you
know double rooks and win the game
uh so that's it i would like to thank
kevin keith robert arthur
and jem al boyd and cruzada.com for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice blitz tournament checking up on
your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day